prisons are the most interesting kind of
or the most useful kinds of shapes that
we can furball you okay so prisms prisms
are 3d shapes don't finish the sentence
they're special 3d shapes they're 3d
shapes that have what we call I'm going
to introduce some word to you and then
I'm just going to show it to you
preserves a 3d shapes that have
something very special what we call
identical cross-sections that's a long
phrase and I'll show you what that looks
like and you'll have a picture for it
they have identical more sections when
cut in a particular way so here's this
formal definition it will be so much
easier to show you so here we go okay so
you'd see it now now I'm gonna hold it
up okay here we go
in case it's a bit too small for you
okay you can see it on the screen this
is a prism okay now my blocks I mean you
guys have used these before my blocks
are a bit um they're bit chunky okay but
you can see it's a prism because here my
colors right each of these colors is
what I call a cross section it's called
a cross section because you're cutting
across the shape okay
so for instance here is one sure I'd
touch you probably here is one of my
cross sections right why my cross
sections and if I took off a few more of
things all of these are identical to one
another right they're all this kind of
shape they're all triangular right they
were triangular so this shape I'd like
you to draw a basic one in your book
you'd have to make it blocky
like mine I made my blocky because I've
done of a choice okay this thing looks
kind of like this you're the way I
and as you can see there's parts of this
shape edges that we can't see so I'm
going to draw them in dotted lines okay
so here's our shape all right
triangular cross-sections triangular
cross-sections right so therefore
because all of the cross-sections are
this same triangle we call this we call
this particular type a triangular prism
right prisms are named after their
cross-section and that's what makes this
particular one because all of these
sections are triangular it's a train
eula prism
okay now I want to draw your attention
to this last little Frazee which seems
like it why is it even there
I have identical cross sections we get
it when cut in a particular way a
particular way we have a look at this
shape right I've cut it along these
lines
right and that's why you've got the
different colors but that's not the only
way you can cut this shape right yeah
you want to suggest something yeah I
could cut across like if we imagine
going up the steps I can cut across the
steps now here's what would happen if
you did that okay you're gonna get this
shape okay
might be a bit small for you let me put
it over here
okay so that's before you kiss it's hard
to see I've cut it right I could cut it
I don't have to cut it you know it costs
it's triangles I've cut these into what
shapes if I go now these are all
rectangles aren't they like here we go
this is a rectangle is a square but this
is this is a rectangle that's a special
kind of a thing okay now here's the
question right you can see you don't
have to see it up close really to notice
that yeah all the rectangles are all
different right like there's this guy
and it's completely different to this
guy and in fact they're all different
right so even though I could cut this
shape into rectangles it's not a
rectangular prism because the
cross-section if I want to be identical
has to be a triangle I'm gonna cut it
along that way does that make sense so
there you go there's our triangular
prism and it's a triangular prism
because we can cut it any way along here
and we've got the same triangle every
time does that make sense